all Bank wassing off the boards and the Celli
Hegel duo in there trying to get a shot and
it's picked up in the corner by Celli Hegel
to the line radish with a drive scores what a
start Darren radish 24 seconds in lightning take
the Zone on the Celli line what else is new they
drive right through the middle get it back to the
point Conor Ingram is just really late going down
yeah he has to stand up on his toes to see the
shot from the point that's not unusual but he's
got a real late drop and this is incredible the
dam has been broken already Conor Ingram in the
last two games against the lightning going back
to last year Brandon heel he was checked there
by moer Sha dery's back there as well for the
coyotes and now it's Celli again Celli back to
H and there's a drive and a save or a blocking
front as engam was screened again Hegel had a
stick on it he might have actually helped save
it here's Hegel again dishes back to headman
headman to Hegel his shot kicked out by Ingram
who really came out to challenge there now one
in front here's a chance drop back for valami
that was McBain who passed up a shot and they
don't get one crer got in trouble there he had
the Pu but all the forwards were changing for
the lightning brown with a drive rebound they
score a rebound popped right back out in front
for the Arizona Coyotes and Keller did not
make any mistake puck in the corner along the
end wall all three forwards for the lightning
changed he decided to double back got the puck
to lber lber got under pressure the coyotes
started to to to roll in the offensive zone
it continued it continued the lightning got
all their forwards out there but still it's
chaos and that's how chaos ends up most of the
time in your own Zone Keller gets a slam dunk
there last coyote to do that was Shane do who's
a franchise Legend here's another chance out in
front kicked aside by vasileski is Arizona long
range shot by radish goes wide rebound picked
up sweps out in front Sherry dropped it back and
no one was there but they keep this thing alive
in front Sherry with a tip nice save by angro
there's technique to fighting but there's also
survival bed off the far boards for Bren point he
steps in scores Bren Point too much 2 [Music] one
that goal is a stoppable shot that that should not
have gone in but Braden point just attacking with
speed the righty on the left wing side and
the go tender Ingram just loses his angle I
guess he's trusting that he can catch it when he
needs I don't think that was deflected but look
where he ends up look where the goal tender
is look how far his right leg is outside the
post up high leads for COV back to point point
try to cut in then a back pass after the initial
play was cut off by Jersey here stamp goes
again Steven and St goes quick shot scores
it's c jro [Music] again now the first goal
of the game went in and now for a second time
Conor Ingram is late going down and it goes
five ho after a terrific shift where they
really had Arizona move it around all three
of them Stam Co coov and point have Arizona
chasing them COV gets way over on the outside
nobody's going to really check him closely
from there but see where he goes remember 1998
when Mark Maguire and Sammy sser were trading
home runs night after night in the Home Run
Derby here they come again M with a shot nice
turnover good four check the four check for the
lightning has been really good just a good read
forward anticipate headman they'll reset snap
down low oh in front great save and the second
shot it's in behind engam he doesn't know where
it is it stays alive there's a what a say and
that was made by I think wow Puck was alive
the lightning kept going and they've got it
back pass across out in front for Point what Puck
move they got going on this one here still goes
SC Stevens stos top shell power play goal 41
Tampa Bay boy are they on a mission in this
game this Top Line and just zipping it around
they've been feeling it since the opening
seconds of the game great passing here stammer
down on one knee outstanding that time he does
go right up under the bar great shots all the
way around I thought coov had scored point and
coov get the assist so COV has got a three point
game on the goal so you know sometimes it's hard
to keep track of all his his numbers here's
one off the post rebound and it's clear by
Arizona lber sends it back around
for croser out of the corner got
a shot rebound scores and that's
the first career goal for Mitchell
chy moving down the the the boards into the
front of the net he's the one that made the
play you have three guys in one white
jersey staring at him he's hanging on
hanging on and give credit to chafy it's
a fortunate bounce off of foot but chafy
is there and he's ready the redirection comes
out to him he has really good instincts good
reactions he's right in that soft area turned
over backand be goes up in the air and it's
pulled down by the coyotes the for check of
that line for the lightning has driven Arizona
crazy here's a centering pass out for Jersy
and he's scores no chance for vasileski as
Jersey found that one a great setup by
Clayton killer and Arizona gets one back
5-2 but that's the second back door play
where the lightning get overloaded and you
have to look around sometimes you plane
just have to count jerseys on the other
team 1 2 3 4 where's the fifth guy there he
is back door nobody's got him nothing vassy
could do VY incredible stretch that had to
be a perfect shot by dery moving in from the
point that's a defenseman and defenseman
get involved in the play now in the NHL
level here's JY again J makes one little
play and then flips it up to open ice for
Walter Marilla Marland check hard there by Brown
jersey looking for options not many pops out to
Glen Denning he [Applause] scores the lightning
forc a turnover to getting on the for check in a
real physical way yeah he's on the receiving
end of a lot of it but it really creates an
atmosphere there then nice work in there also
the puck is loose because of that Collision
chaffy comes in and help you keep your sticks
active Marilyn gets back active again and then
the The Crafty centerman Glenn Denning is there in
support and also in defensive position and there
again liberg got tangled up down there in the
corner both guys go down near side it's stanos
even stanos Cycles it back around waiting for
in the opposite corn is the lber to grer groer
gave it up turning it fir it across was cooly
to Crow it was behind the net and that's where
he gets caught in a bad position again and
this is where the puck goes into the back
of the [Music] net that went just into the
reach of Paul rolls to stanos stanos Cuts
away for his man here's Paul again Kudo shoots
big save by angram get in his face Nick Paul's
not going to let that happen Brown in front of
the net there's the shot by coer off and in and
the lightning will stretch their win streak on
home ICE to six in a row with a 63 Victory final